bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 7 juillet l'état apporte des aides
complémentaires financière aux familles
ayant des petits des grands enfants les
allocations logement seront versés
jusqu'à l'âge de 21 ans rapport d'
enquête sur la catastrophe du tunnel du
mont blanc du 24 mars dernier
catastrophe qui les fait 39 morts des
dizaines de recommandations sont
formulées pour améliorer la sécurité du
tunnel avant sa réouverture
un médecin de seine-et-marne mis en
examen pour avoir prescrit à des
toxicomanes un produit de substitution
pourtant légal les contrats des
téléphones portables devront être revues
sont souvent illisibles et plus
respectueux du droit des consommateurs
festival de musique d'evian avec une
rencontre unique entre rostropovitch le
violoncelliste et ravi shankar illustres
joueurs et compositeur de sitar indien
la famille objet d attention pécuniaire
gouvernementale lors de la
traditionnelle conférence annuelle sur
la famille le premier ministre a annoncé
plusieurs mesures dead en faveur des
grands comme des petits enfants tout en
maintenant l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire comme l'an passé à 1600 francs
l'explication sébastien guibert et eric
mézil
le rendez vous était d'importance pour
les associations familiales et certains
syndicats
cette quatrième conférence de la famille
constitue l occasion de rappeler leur
credo au gouvernement c'est la famille
c'est l'essentiel est donc ce que l'on
apporte à la famille cet investissement
c'est pas une dépense mais
l'investissement cette année sera limité
pas question pour le gouvernement de
lionel jospin de bouleverser le régime
d'allocations familiales ni d'alourdir
les comptes de la sécurité sociale et de
l'état le premier ministre a par exemple
annoncé que l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire serait maintenue comme l'an
passé à 1600 francs par enfant
mais il a souhaité que cette aide
deviennent automatiques et qu'elles ne
dépendent plus du bon vouloir des
gouvernements
autre mesure l'âge limite des enfants
pour le calcul des allocations logement
sera porté à 21 ans l'an prochain au
lieu de 20 aujourd'hui 175 mille
familles bénéficieront de cet
allongement
même principe pour le complément
familial soixante mille familles
nombreuses seront cette fois concerné
des mesures que les associations
familiales ont diversement appréciée ça
veut dire que sur 7 milliards qui devait
arriver aux familles un milliard trois
qui arriveront et que pour beaucoup de
familles c'est 1500 francs de manque à
gagner donc c'est un coup assez dur le
premier ministre a pris l'engagement que
les masses financières consacrées aux
familles évoluerait désormais au moins
comme la richesse nationale
et ça c'est une nouveauté mais
l'essentiel pour le gouvernement était
peut-être de relancer la concertation
avec les associations
un an après avoir retiré le projet
controversé du plafonnement de
ressources des allocations familiales et
le problème des jeunes adultes à la
charge des parents étaient au coeur de
cette conférence annuelle de la famille
c'est effectivement une situation que
connaissent beaucoup de cellule
familiale
les jeunes attendrait 26 en moyenne
avant de quitter leurs parents alors
voici un exemple partiel mais
significatif avec le reportage de
cyrille devaud et alain le catch au
effectués dans le val de marne à créteil
water si t'arrives pas à dire waters tu
mets web pendant l'année scolaire
aurélie donne des cours d'anglais à des
collégiens débutant chaque samedi elles
vont aussi des vêtements dans une
boutique des petits boulots qui lui
rapporte environ 2000 francs par mois
d'argent de poche cnca pour sortir comme
tout le monde on sortir le sens où le
vendredi puis samedi soir pour tout le
reste
aurélie compte sur ses parents la
voiture un cadeau de papa
aurélie a de bons résultats à la fac
elle entre en deuxième année de deug
mais pour l'essence il faut encore
négocier avec maman alors il ya là j'en
ai fini ouais signifie ni mais jamais
comme j'aime le faire un plein d'essence
les j'ai pu j'ai pris l'argent sur mon
compte
aurélie a 20 ans elle reste à la charge
de ses parents comme trois jeunes sur
quatre de son âge elle fait partie de
ceux qu'on appelle les jeunes adultes
il habite toujours au domicile familial
bien après leur majorité souvent jusqu'à
26 ans
deux causes à cette nouvelle tendance
des études prolongées ou la difficulté
de trouver un emploi transport études
loisirs habillement la vie d'un jeune
adulte coûte cher surtout depuis
l'apparition du téléphone portable chez
les b doucheurs il n'y en a trois
car il ya trois enfants aurélie son
frère jean-philippe 16 ans sa soeur
séverine 21 ans trois bouches à nourrir
sans compter flipper l'epagnol de la
femme il ya trois enfants logés blanchis
ça coûte 6000 francs par mois
normal disent les parents le prix à
payer pour avoir ses enfants à la maison
poursuivant des études
c'est globalement c'est une charge qu on
va assumer jusqu'à 25 26 ans maintenant
la note peut s'alourdir à 4000 francs
par mois et par enfant lorsqu'il faut
acheter un piano payer les vacances ou
les livres scolaires seul papa travaille
il est médecin et gagne confortablement
sa vie mais lorsque maman pressée
comptes en fin de mois
les 1000 francs d'allocations familiales
sont les bienvenus en france
580 mille familles ont deux ou trois
enfants à charge
elle demande l'allongement des
allocations jusqu'à l'âge de 22 ans
alors afin de mieux apprécier la
situation actuelle des familles et des
jeunes adultes demeurer dans le giron
parental
l'athée limoisin benoît thevenet se sont
livrés à un exercice de mémoire
comment la famille et les meurtres
familiaux ont évolué ces dernières
décennies et soeurs en distinguant trois
périodes volées ou fausses
onze enfants en 1964 ses parents mérite
la médaille de la famille nombreuse un
tel foyer n'est déjà plus la norme
le modèle familial de l'après-guerre a
vécu car la famille des années 50 et
jusqu'au milieu des années 60 est une
famille nombreuse
40% des foyers comptent trois enfants et
plus maman ne travaille pas et tout le
monde vit sous le même toit à partir du
milieu des années 60 aux etats-unis et
68 en france est une revendication de
liberté individuelle et ce moment là on
va rentrer dans un modèle familial dans
lequel chacun va vouloir avoir sa vie à
lui avec mai 68 puis woodstock les
années 70 sans âme effectivement une
nouvelle ère
les fleurs l'amour et les pattes d'eph
c'est la montée en flèche de
l'individualisme
en quelques années tout change la
contraception se généralise grâce à la
loi neuwirth voter en 1967
la famille se réduit le schéma le plus
courant c'est papa maman et deux enfants
les femmes veulent maîtriser leur
fécondité elles veulent aussi travailler
nouvelle révolution de la cellule
familiale veut dire que la femme a
modifié
cellule familiale par ses aspirations
ses revendications mais ce serait faux
aussi de dire que l'homme ne compte pas
et bien évidemment la place de l'homme
se redéfinit et c'est ça qui est
passionnant aujourd'hui c'est que la
place de chacun est en redéfinition
redéfinition dans les années 80 et 90
conséquence de l'augmentation du nombre
des divorces
un tiers des couples mariés se sépare
aujourd'hui en france 13% des familles
sont dites monoparentales mais pendant
que le couple explose les fratries se
recompose vive la famille tribu chaque
conjoint apporte ses enfants dans le
foyer où ils restent de plus en plus
tard le chômage est passé par là priez
d'aider les enfants les grands-parents
redistribue une part de plus en plus
importante de leurs revenus
c'est l'avènement d'une nouvelle famille
unie par nécessité pour résister à la
crise publication du rapport d'enquêté
sur la catastrophe du tunnel du mont
blanc du 24 mars dernier quarante-et-une
recommandations sont formulées deux
critiques principal dans ce rapport
l'absence de stratégie franco italienne
dans le domaine de la sécurité et les
problèmes de ventilation de l' ouvrage
explications stephen britney françois
privant pas de grandes révélations sur
les causes de l'incendié du 24 mars
dernier
si les délais d'alerté d'intervention
sont considérés comme normaux
les experts pointent du doigt une erreur
des responsables italiens au lieu
d'extraire les fumées les pompiers ont
insufflé de l'air frais dans le tunnel
conséquence immédiate le feu s'est
propagé très vite pour éviter une
nouvelle catastrophe de ce type
certains experts ne voit qu'une solution
efficace construire un deuxième tunnel
parallèles qui ont ce qu'on a du tunnel
on peut prévoir d
des portes entre les deux tunnels qui
permettent la montre paillasson de fumée
et entend donc assez facilement mettre
les gens à l'abri dans un tunnel enfumé
cette idée a pourtant été rejeté
beaucoup trop cher pour les membres de
la commission d' enquête
il propose donc des solutions
alternatives d'abord pour renforcer la
sécurité du tunnel
les experts préconisent d'installer tous
les 100 mètres des trappes télécommande
et un système qui permettrait d'évacuer
les fumées au plus vite
il suggère également de doubler le
nombre de refuges de 18 actuellement
on passerait à 36 tous reliés pour aider
les usagers à rejoindre la sortie
deuxième type de recommandation les
conditions de circulation dans le tunnel
grâce à des contrôles à l'entrée on
pourrait fixer un espacement minimum
entre les véhicules éviter le risque de
collision
ces contrôles permettrait de vérifier le
chargement des poids lourds et interdire
l'accès à ceux transportant des matières
trop dangereuse le rapport insiste
également sur la mauvaise coopération
entre les équipes française et italienne
les experts proposent donc la création
d'un comité technique commun celui ci
permettrait d'élaborer un plan de
secours coordonnés mais ce ne sont ici
que des recommandations aux deux
gouvernements de les retenir ou pas
et le bilan de cette catastrophe est
maintenant établi à 39 morts pour
l'association de défense des victimes de
l'incendié on pouvait espérer mieux que
ce rapport et on s'étonne que la
construction d'un second tunnel était
écartée pour des problèmes de coût
reportage virginie fichet thiery simonet
jean pierre petit os a découvert les
premiers éléments de ce rapport dans son
quotidien local le 24 mars dernier il a
perdu quatre membres de sa famille dans
la catastrophe
aujourd'hui il ne lui reste que la
froideur d'un compte-rendu administratif
qui ne me suffit pas c'est pas vraiment
ce que l'on attendait on attendait
beaucoup plus peut-être plus des
responsabilités on attendra je pense le
rapport judiciaire avec impatience nous
apportera certainement les causes de
cette catastrophe
dans le cadre de la procédure judiciaire
une reconstitution du drame devrait
avoir lieu en septembre prochain
les familles espèrent enfin de trouver
les réponses
seul capable d'effacer le sentiment
d'amertume laissés par les
recommandations des experts
la plupart des mesures qui sont proposés
sont des mesures qui ont existé dans le
tunnel
les conditions de sécurité la limitation
du nombre de véhicules les vérifications
des substances qui y transitent
la seule chose qui est neuf mais qui est
frappé au coin du bon sens et de se dire
ah bah tiens dans ce tunnel il faudrait
peut-être que il y ait une un système de
sécurité unifiée des deux côtés entre
l'italie et la france
est-ce qu'il faut 39 morts pour se
rendre compte d'une chose aussi évidente
c'est une question dans la vallée de
chamonix aussi les élus jugent ces
mesures
presque anachronique on a un peu le
sentiment dans cette affaire contre est
le symptôme plutôt que le mal
c'est à dire qu'on s'attache à des
préconisations qui permettront de
remettre en route une installation hors
qu'il faudrait prendre des mesures
beaucoup plus fondamental de
réorientation de la politique fret en
france et à travers les alpes la société
d'exploitation du tunnel a remis
aujourd'hui son propre rapport ces
conclusions sont identiques pour elle
dix mois de travaux sont nécessaires
mais rien ne pourra être entrepris avant
la fin de l' enquête judiciaire et du
côté italien au val d'aoste et sans
attendre la publication de ce rapport ce
sont surtout les conséquences
économiques désastreuses qui sont
constatés dans la région
la prolongation de la fermeture du
tunnel est redoutée dans les italiens du
val d'aoste reportage alain de chalvron
et dominique merlin on ne passe plus le
tunnel est fermé hermétiquement au loin
clignote une lumière est encore plus
loin il y aller reste de l' incendie du
24 mars avec la fermeture du tunnel du
mont blanc c'est toute la région
italienne du val d'aoste qui est entré
en crise voici un relais d'autoroute
il employait 16 personnes le patron est
seul désormais oui mais avant là où nous
avions 100 clients maintenant nous n'en
avons plus qu'un
nous avons donc une réduction d'activité
de 99%
pareil pour la station service elle
était d'autant plus rentable que
l'essence est légèrement moins cher en
italie qu'en france mais nain c'est fini
c'est lé désert c'est la mort parce que
personne ne passe plus chez l'eau s'il
n'y avait que l'autoroute et les
activités directement liées au trafic
mais en amont c'est toute la vie de la
région qui est en panne
commerces fermés hôtels fermés il
faisait vivre douze mille personnes sur
cent mille habitants
un des axes de communication les plus
stratégiques d'europe est redevenu le
cul-de-sac qu'il était avant le tunnel
nous avons bâti notre entreprise nous
avons fait nos investissements en
comptant sur cette voie de liaison dans
ce moment il y avait beaucoup d'hôtels
beaucoup de magasins qui ne réussissent
pas à payer leurs dettes
techniquement les responsables italiens
du tunnel estime qu'en moins d'un an
les installations pourraient être
réparés si du moins la justice française
donne son feu vert
magistrate le juge français a décidé de
faire une reconstitution du drame du
tunnel d'habitat et ceci nous préoccupe
car cela va rallonger les délais je
n'ose plus imaginer ce qui se produira
si cela se passe ainsi
une crise irréversible sans tunnel mais
avec ces beautés naturelles et ses
villages pittoresques le malade peut
espérer passer encore une saison de
grâce aux aides de l'état
mais guère plus
l'ancien préfet de corse bernard bonnet
remis en liberté vendredi dernier a
changé d'avocat et adressé une lettre au
juge d'instruction lui suggérant
d'enquêté à l'hôtel matignon auprès de
deux conseillers du premier ministre
dans une lettre publiée par
l'hebdomadaire l'express
l'aide que nous avons pu le vérifier
monsieur bernard bonnet raconte ses
contacts réguliers avec deux
collaborateurs de lionel jospin
commentaires michele finn la lettre de
bernard bonnet et daté du 2 juillet ce
jour là l'ex préfet de corse sont des
prisons en promettant des
rebondissements
quelques quelques coups de théâtre à
brève échéance
l' affaire commence la lettre que
bernard bonnet écrit ce jour-là est
adressée au juge cambérou chargé de
l'instruction sur l'incendié de la
paillote le préfet il parle de 2 proche
conseiller de lionel jospin
clotilde valter conseillère technique
qui l'avait au téléphone dit-il deux à
trois fois par jour et alain christnacht
conseiller personnel de lionel jospin
bernar venet affirme les avoir
rencontrés le 27 avril dernier c'est à
dire dix jours avant son placement en
garde à vue au cours de cet entretien
écrit-il je leur ai précisément exposer
les éléments dont je dispose est sur l'
incendie de la paillote chez francis
madame clotilde valter a soigneusement
noté mes propos dans un de ces cahiers
personnel madame valter ajoute le préfet
a pour habitude de consigner dans ses
cahiers le contenu des conversations
téléphoniques ainsi que les points
essentiels des entretiens
la lettre ne précise pas ce que l'ex
préfet de corse
ali réellement ce jour là haut
conseiller de matignon mais elle suggère
au juge d'aller consulter pour sont
informés les cahiers personnel de
clotilde valter à l'hôtel matignon
on accueille ce premier coup de théâtre
de bernar venet avec beaucoup de calme
cela ne change rien dit on au fond du
dossier si le juge demande des éléments
sur les cahiers s'il souhaite entendre
les membres du cabinet de lionel jospin
il n'y aura a firm ton aucun problème
l'interpellation ce matin cargèse en
corse du sud de quatre personnes celles
ci seraient des proches d' yvan colonna
actuellement toujours recherché dans
l'enquêté sur l'assassinât du préfet
claude erignac les quatre personnes dont
l'identité n'a pas été communiquée ont
été placés en garde à vue à ajaccio
la cour d'appel de grenoble a condamné à
deux ans de prison dont un an ferme la
responsable de la communauté aux russes
installés à la coucourde dans la drôme
cette femme baptisée maïté étaient
poursuivis pour non-assistance à
personne en danger et exercice illégal
de la médecine
elle fait maintenant l'objet d'un mandat
d'arrêt les magistrats de la cour de
cassation sont saisi d'une demande de
révision d'une condamnation à 20 ans de
prison
condamnation visant jean louis turquin
un vétérinaire de la région niçoise
accusés de la mort de son fils charles
édouard les jurés de la cour d'assises
de nice l'avait reconnu coupable en 1997
mais une enquête menée par un comité de
soutien aurait retrouvé la trace de
l'enfant
il serait bien vivant mais retenu dans
une communauté en israël et se fait
nouveau pourrait ouvrir la procédure de
révision du procès de jean louis turc un
reportage s mina farber et diane richard
jean louis turquin attend ce moment
depuis le verdict le dépôt d'une requête
en révision de son procès son avocat
estime qu'il a les preuves que son fils
charles édouard est vivant le
vétérinaire est soulagé n'y croit
fermement
parce qu'il est sur lui qu'il est
innocent et vous vous y croyez
changer pour lui c'était qu'il y a deux
ans jean-louis turques ainsi placide
pendant son procès ressort effondré la
cour d'assises des alpes-maritimes vient
de le condamner à 20 ans de prison pour
le meurtre de son fils charles édouard
en 91
l'enfant de 8 ans disparaît alors qu'il
dort à ses côtés la sphère prend une
tournure peu ordinaire jean-louis
turquin avoue à sa femme qu'il a bien
tué charles-edouard des aveux qu'elle
enregistre à son insu pas d'autres
preuves pas de cadavre et l'enquète
rebondi en 94
le petit turquin seraient vivants cachés
en israël des témoins font le
déplacement au procès sans convaincre
les jurés mais pour la défense ces
pistes existent bien
une récente enquête privée abouti dans
une école rabbinique qui abriterait un
adolescent adopté c'est un garçon qui a
le même âge que charlene en turc 1 c'est
à dire environ 16 ans qui se trouve en
israël depuis huit ans c'est à dire très
exactement depuis l'époque de la
disparition de serge mort turc a qui
remonte au mois de mars
991 c'est un garçon auquel on a dit
qu'il ne pouvait pas rencontrer sa mère
parce qu'elle n'était pas juive à qui on
a dit que son père serait mort en prison
bref autant d'éléments qui nous font
indubitablement croire que c'est en
france et charles bordeleau qu'à un
religieux d'une association israélienne
confirme cette information mais aucun
test génétique n'a été réalisé pour le
moment les avocats de michel ballanger 7
kg haine de tout commentaire
jean-louis turquin lui vient d'être
transféré à la prison de fresnes
avec l'espoir que les magistrats de la
cour de cassation prennent au sérieux
c'est pete israélienne un médecin
généraliste de seine-et-marne a été mis
en examen et placé sous contrôle
judiciaire pour avoir selon la justice
faciliter l'usagé de produits
stupéfiants en l'occurrence cette femme
médecin qui est soutenu par de
nombreuses organisations de lutte contre
la toxicomanie a prescrit du subutex
c'est à dire un produit de substitution
parfaitement légale reportage soleil
dupuis christian leroux comme tous les
matins depuis trois semaines le docteur
la barre filtre ses messages car la
justice l'ont interdit de voir certains
patients donc là on ne répondait pas
puisqu'on demande le plus souvent il
s'agit de preuves et que laurent est un
des patients qui étaient en location
depuis quatre ans chutent pas comme
interdiction de voir ses patients
toxicomanes car le docteur la barre est
mise en examen depuis le 8 juin dernier
pour facilitation de l' usage de
stupéfiants les enquêteurs lui
reprochent de nombreuses irrégularités
dans ces dossiers notamment la
prescription à de trop fortes doses de
subutex un substitut à l'héroïne
particularité de ce médicament il peut
être prescrit depuis trois ans par
n'importe quel médecin généraliste
la durée du traitement ne peut excéder
28 jours
à ce terme l'ordonance doit être
renouvelée mais rien n'interdit aux
patientes de multiplier cette opération
en changeant de médecins le subutex
hamas et peut ensuite être revendues
dans la rue une aubaine pour les dealers
cet abus et difficilement contrôlables
par les médecins qui prescrivent le
médicament le mode il de la mise en
examen je suis tout à fait dans la même
situation qu'elle est nous sommes
quelques centaines voire des milliers en
france est dans la même situation
parce que en délivrant du subutex aux
usagers de drogues
si on considère que le subutex est un
stupéfiant
on n'en facilite l'usagé puisque on le
prescrit d'après le ministère de
l'intérieur l'année dernière les décès
par overdose ont baissé de 80% et lin
délinquance liée à l' usage de
stupéfiants a fortement diminué pour ses
médecins traitants cela ne fait aucun
doute c'est le résultat des traitements
de substitution
la police espagnole a opéré une saisie
sur un pétrolier navigue en plein
atlantique une saisie exceptionnelle de
10 tonnes de cocaïne destinées aux
trafiquants et européens il y avait
également 208 kilos d'héroïne
probablement d'origine colombienne 54
personnes ont été arrêtées en serbie
l'opposition à slobodan milosevic donne
de la voix et démontre jour après jour
sa volonté d'en finir avec le président
yougoslave dans plusieurs régions du
pays mais principalement leskovac à 250
km au sud de belgrade les manifestants
ont affronté hier soir encore les forces
de sécurité serbes tandis qu'à use it
chez l'ancien maire de belgrade a
réclamé le départ de slobodan milosevic
commentaires gérard griesbeck
c'était son premier meeting depuis son
retour en serbie
craignant pour sa vie sera jean djich
l'ancien maire de belgrade s'était exilé
pendant la guerre au monténégro
poursuivi pour insoumission il risque 20
ans de prison
aujourd'hui il essaye de s'imposer comme
leader de l'opposition
d'abord nous voulons la démission de
milosevic et après on fera des élections
si l'on va aux élections avec milosevic
il va encore tricher et nous voler nos
voix un meeting sous le signe de la
serbie traditionnel la sainte trinité
l'hymne national et pour la première
fois un pop à la tribune preuve de
l'engagement de l'église orthodoxe aux
côtés de l'opposition et non sans humour
on pouvait lire sur une banderole
milosevic 16 de nous défendre ce qui
m'angoisse le plus c'est que les paysans
ont été volés moi je suis une paysanne
ils veulent continuer à nous voler mais
nous on n'a plus rien à donner je n'en
peux plus ça suffit avec la terreur de
faux couple monstrueux pour le moment
l'opposition compte ses troupes en
défilant chaque jour ce soir une
nouvelle réunion est prévue à leskovac à
l'appel de vuk draskovic preuve que
l'opposition relève la tête mais qu'elle
est toujours incapable de s'unir et au
kosovo le pont principal de la ville de
mitrovica était de nouveau utilisé par
les albanais mais sa traversée se fait
sous surveillance le pont marque en
effet la division de la ville entre les
deux communautés d'un côté les albanais
de l'autre côté les serbes les forces
françaises chargées du maintien de la
paix à mitrovica avait mené de longs
pourparlers avec les responsables des
deux communautés avant cette réouverture
symbolique mais ce sont les manifestants
albanais qui ont quelque peu précipité
les choses
reportage valérie cure new et frédéric
basket en tête de la manifestation
l'armée française
pour une tentative en force faire
traverser ces 5000 albanais de mitrovic
heures le pont de la rivière y brille un
pont que la population serbe située de
l'autre côté les empêche de franchir
pour la première fois depuis quatre mois
ils se croisent à nouveau sur cette rive
leurs sourires esquissés sont ceux de la
fierté de part et d'autre
injures slogan le face à face va durer
plus d'une heure sans incident une
première à mitrovic à le cortège va
traverser la ville encadrés par les
troupes françaises devant une majorité
de serbes un puissant mais pas résigné
c'est la serbie si le kosovo et serbes
la guerre va recommencer vous verrez
côté albanel ou chicken avait calmé les
esprits avant et pendant la
manifestation
ce qu'il voulait c'est tenir tête aux
serbes leur prouver que la ville leur
appartient ce que nous voulons c'est que
cette ville soit libre et ouverte à tous
pour les serbes et les albanais toutes
les communautés comme en démocratie que
tout le monde soit libre de circuler dès
la manifestation terminée les militaires
français ont levé le barrage à l'entrée
de ce pont c'est un pari psychologique
que l'armée française a lancé pour
tenter de faire baisser la tension entre
les deux communautés
mais en attendant la haine et la peur
d'une rive à l'autre se font toujours
face et rares sont ceux qui ont osé
franchir le pont depuis un accord de
paix en sierra leone cet accord a été
obtenu par quatre chefs d'état d'afrique
de l'ouest est signé à lomé au togo il
pourrait mettre fin à neuf ans de guerre
civile à des massacres des tueries qui
aurait fait plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de morts
ruiné le pays et provoqué une famine
grandissante parmi les rescapés des
affrontements commentaires patrice
romedenne
décrire 8 ans de guerre en sierra leone
c'est prendre le risque de
l'approximation dans la confusion règne
dans ce pays désormais ruinait les
acteurs tout d'abord envers le président
cabba il incarne un pouvoir contre
lequel se dresse des rebelles infiltrés
un peu partout dans la population pour
leur faire la chasse il a recours aux
services de l'ecomog la force
d'intervention ouest africaine dont les
soldats ratisse chaque quartier et aux
besoins n'hésite pas à chasser les
civils histoire d'y voir plus clair
conséquence sur les quatre millions et
demi d'habitants que compte le pays
la moitié connaît l'exil legends et
rumine sa vengeance
quentin rebelles tombent aux mains des
civils voilà ce que cela donne
al'inverse tenta simin refuse d'épouser
la cause de la guérilla on lui coupe une
ou deux mains plus de 6000 morts sans
compter les amputer les blessés les
brûler à qui l'on annonce ce soir que la
paix est signé et que les rebelles
entrent au gouvernement
prudence tout de même ce n'est pas la
première fois que l'on signale accord
dans ce pays où plus qu'ailleurs les
seuls traité qui compte sont ceux
conclus entre les arrières pensées
le premier ministre israélien ehud barak
rencontrera vendredi le président
égyptien hosni moubarak et dimanche le
président palestinien yasser arafat
c'est donc une relance effective du
processus de paix avec également
l'annoncent pour le 15 juillet la
déplacement du chef du gouvernement
israélien à washington
les contrats des téléphones mobiles en
france devront être revus la secrétaire
d'état en charge de la consommation
marylise lebranchu appuie les
revendications des associations de
consommateurs mécontents de la rédaction
des contrats de téléphonie mobile et
comme il est actuellement 13 millions et
demi d'abonnés disposant de portable
parfois qualifiée d'insupportable en
public
la tâche de réécriture des contrats est
importante
reportage yann front thiviers rancoeur
raymond schappler comme cette jeune
fille les français sont de plus en plus
nombreux à utiliser un téléphone
portable
en tout ils sont 13 millions et demi
aujourd'hui de plus en plus nombreux
également à se plaindre du manque de
clarté et de lisibilité de leur contrat
c'est très compliqué si vous parler
vraiment de ça moi ça fait quatre ans
que je suis dedans mais des fois c'est
pas évident du tout de suite mme aubry
de l'ange et l'impression des critiques
d interrogation relayée hier par
marylise lebranchu secrétaire d'état à
la consommation a tué par des contrats
soient claires visible de la même
manière sur internet avec des fameux 3
mois gratuits chaque tout ça entraîne
des accidents parce que les gens n'ont
pas le contrat de vente eux ont des
éléments les plus attrayants mais non
pas les éléments les plus contraignants
donc il faut que l'attrayant et
contraignant se rejoignent principal
reproche des consommateurs la
possibilité de résilier son contrat vont
un autre grief la qualité du service et
les tarifs pratiqués depuis un an
plus d'un millier de plaintes ont ainsi
atterri sur les bureaux des
fonctionnaires de la répression des
fraudes et de la commission des clauses
abusives
face à cette grogne les trois principaux
opérateurs france télécom bouygues et
sfr ont décidé de réagir et de modifier
les points litigieux
on est prêts à dialoguer consommateurs
dès l'été dès cet été pour proposer aux
consommateurs de mettre dans nos
contrats dès la rentrée de septembre des
claustras écrite conformément aux
recommandations de la commission dès la
rentrée prochaine les utilisateurs
devraient donc y voir plus clair dans
leur contrat au risque de payer plus
cher surtout engagé là dessus sur
l'engagement buzz mans / dernières
nouveautés annoncées pour l'année
prochaine
un groupe de travail réunissant les
professionnels du secteur devrait être
créé afin de définir un code de bonne
conduite
certains jouets et articles de
puériculture en plastique souple
destinés à être mis en bouche par les
enfants de moins de 3 ans serait
dangereux
un arrêté de suspension de la vente de
ces jouets tels les anneaux de dentition
où les sucettes de puériculture mais
attention les tétines ne sont pas
concernés vient d'être annoncée par le
gouvernement
l'explication romane bonne en france aux
vallées et philippe naudy seulement
certains de ces objets de puériculture
doivent être retirés de la vente pendant
un an
il s'agit exclusivement danault et de
hochet de dentition dont le pvc a été
fabriquée à partir de phtalates un
produit qui permet d' assouplir le
plastique ces objets ni en bouche de
façon répétée par les enfants
représenterait à terme un risque
sanitaire
cette mesure de précaution fait suite à
des résultats d'expérimentations menées
sur des animaux
les phtalates sont toxiques pour le foie
pour les glandes et avec une
répercussion sur la reproduction sur les
capacités de reproduction en laboratoire
sur l'animal en france si différents
types de phtalates sont déjà interne
mais depuis deux ans la majorité des
fabricants utilisent de plus en plus des
produits de substitution
même si pour eux les risques liés aux
phtalates n'ont jamais été prouvée chez
l'homme plutôt que d'interdire
totalement ce genre de produit parce
qu'on se rend bien compte que à
certaines limites qui ne sont pas du
tout nocifs pour la santé des enfants
je pense qu'on aurait préféré comme ce
qui est déjà fait pour les métaux lourds
pour les jouets avoir une réglementation
qui fixe des limites à ne pas dépasser
des limites de produits qui migrent dans
la bouche c'est à dire qu'il se
transfère de la note dentition à la
bouche de l'enfant
impossible pour le consommateur de s'y
retrouver aucun étiquetage n'indique la
présence ou non de phtalates dans les
produits en revanche les sucettes et
tétines en silicone ou caoutchouc ne
sont pas concernés du sport du cyclisme
avec le tour de france à l'issue de la
quatrième étape disputée entre laval et
blois le maillot jaune est toujours sur
les épaules de l'estonien kirsi pew
étape sans trop de problèmes pour les
coureurs ce soir jean marie leblanc le
directeur général du tour de france
évoqué la situation de richard virenque
comme celle d'un coureur comme les
autres une sorte de climat de retour à
la normale voulu avec obstination par
plusieurs équipes qui firent parler
d'elle beaucoup l'année dernière pour
cause de dopage
parmi ces équipes festina reportage
florent gautreau philippe deslandes les
mêmes gestes à la même cadence les mêmes
supporters l'équipe festina est toujours
là et laurent brochard signe autant
d'autographes que l'année dernière
cette popularité c'est ce qui a décidé
miguel rodriguez de patron des montres
festina a continué d'investir dans le
cyclisme à hauteur de 20 millions de
francs par an pour le plus grand bonheur
des supporters
laurent et l'épée tina ont été pris à
partie mais toutes les équipes
c'était la même
un cinéma et comme pour quoique eux ont
payé puisque les autres et dernière on
en a produit les disques de freins il y
un an la découverte d'un système de
dopage organisé avait entraîné
l'exclusion de l'équipe festina du tour
98 aujourd'hui virenque du l'ue et du
fonds ont changé d'équipé steffens a
arrêté sa carrière et pascal hervé n'a
pas été invité à faire le tour chez
festina on cherche à gommer se passer
alors on n'est pas traumatisé
aujourd'hui on a oublié ce qui s'est
passé l'année dernière et puis enfin on
l'a oublié
dire que il faut nous en parler pour
françois rappel du passé faisons table
rase
l'équipe du fabricant de montres a fait
sa révolution de jeunes coureurs souvent
inconnus du grand public ont pris la
place des stars les visages ont changé
les objectifs aussi l'équipe de madouas
se satisferait d'une simple victoire
d'étape
en fait si festina est toujours là c'est
que le retour sur investissement est
payant malgré les affaires malgré la
modestie de la nouvelle équipe
les ventes de montres ne cesse
d'augmenter aujourd'hui entre laval et
blois leaf estimant sont restés discrets
l'étape la plus rapide de toute
l'histoire du tour courue à plus de 50
km heure s'est terminée au sprint avec
la première victoire cette année sur le
tour de çi pollinique devant l'allemande
zabel qui se spécialise dans les 2e
place un peu à l'écart
loin des récompenses l'équipe festina
s'habituer à sa nouvelle vie
la vie d'une équipe presque comme les
autres
à evian à la grange aux lacs les
rencontres musicales qui se poursuivront
jusqu'à la fin du mois de juillet
présentait hier soir un concert unique
et exceptionnel le violoncelliste
michelas votre pompiste jouait en
compagnie de l'indien ravi shankar
joueur de sitar prestigieux c'était une
grande première entre le classique
européen et l'inspiration indienne
reportage michel mompontet et jacques
gérard quand une masse d'air chaud
rencontre une masse d'air froid cela
fait un orage cela tout le monde le sait
et bien entre musiciens cela fonctionne
de la même manière
observons donc tout d'abord la masse
d'air chaud venant d'inde et à fournes
ont ravi shanker musiciens courroux de
80 ans
il est accompagné par sa fille et son
élève
anouchka 18 printemps comme un zéphyr à
présent n'est pas une musique que
spéciale pour arrêter l'oral et toute
façon c'est pas nous qui l'avons ramené
cet orage face à eux donc une masse
d'air froid observons là elle vient de
russie et elle est tout aussi colossale
rostropovitch monsieur violence est le
représentant le plus imposant de la
musique occidentale
seulement voilà pour la première fois de
sa gigantesque carrière rostropovitch
accepte et hier soir de se risquer sur
le terrain de la musique indienne de
champ car et de sa fille mais la premier
problème la musique indienne ne s'écrit
pas champ car c'est donc débrouillé pour
offrir une partition à son ami
rostropovitch
autre problème le violoncelle comme tous
les instruments occidentaux comptent 12
notes dans une gamme
star au moins 36 entre eux pour
s'accorder autant monter l'anapurna en
bicyclette mais entre les champ kharir
rostropovitch et ses barrières vont peu
à peu s'effondrer pour laisser parler la
musique universelle comme unique ou
directement de coeur à quelques autres
musiques dax la musique européenne comme
elle est écrite et plus confortables en
inde la musique et plus vécue comme un
dialogue
hier soir ou de l'orage annoncé ce sous
un tonnerre mais un tonnerre
d'applaudissements avant de refermer ce
journal je vous rappelle deux
informations nous avons développé lors
de la conférence annuelle sur la famille
le gouvernement décide de reconduire la
location d'être pour la rentrée scolaire
de 1600 francs et de prolonger jusqu'à
21 ans
l'aide au logement le rapport d
expertise après la catastrophe du tunnel
du mont blanc qui a coûté la vie à 39
personnes mettent en cause le manque de
coordination entre la france et l'italie
et le système de ventilation
en quelques secondes la météo avec
sophie davant à 0 heures 20 le dernier
journal de la rédaction avec florence
duprat suivi des meilleurs moments du
cercle de cette année david heap le fait
demain c'est 1,50 dans les 4 vérités
françoise laborde recevra nicole notât
la secrétaire général de la cfdt à 13h
carole gaessler à paris et rachid arhab
parmi les cyclistes du tour à demain à
20 heures
bonsoir merci